so yesterday we covered Joe Jonas and
Sophie Turner's divorce and it is
alleged they are rumors so we don't know
for sure
um that she was out partying drinking
her life away and you know instead of
being a mother instead of being a wife
and you know um this has set the
internet Ablaze I guess I guess I found
out wives and mothers are supposed to be
out drinking till 2 A.M
and you're a misogynist and a bad person
and when you claim
that wives aren't really supposed to be
doing that that's yeah that just sounds
amazing so here's a clip um I think it
was off of The View for the record you
can like to party and still be a good
mom
[Applause]
I feel like it's super I think it's very
dangerous territory to start saying well
you're either a mom or you like to go
and party because I think she's young
what we have fought for as feminist is
you can do and be it all so yeah right
do you hear how she's saying you can do
both
and everyone's cheering and clapping
around all the women here's the problem
and kids grow up and they look back on
their childhood and all those women
clapping on this crazy lady are not
gonna have to deal with the consequences
of your kids hating you because you're
partying instead of being a mother your
kids resenting you because you weren't
doing the right thing you weren't home
raising them and feminists will parade
this stuff on they'll clap their hands
they'll say all the stuff that sound
sounds nice while they on me for
being honest and telling you you can't
do it all one day they figure out that
their mom was a selfish woman that would
rather put her kid in daycare and have a
stranger raise it rather than do it
herself because she wanted to have it
all she wanted to have the social life
she wanted to have the work life she
wanted to do everything and do you know
who gets the short end of the stick in
all of these situations it's children
and those are the ones that deserve
everything kids are they are the
innocent ones in all all of this and
this is why I harp so hard on Modern
women because our actions the things
that we choose to do being super
getting a divorce going out and partying
representing your family in that way who
does it impact the most the kids because
now they are the harlot's children the
harlots and and we we as women we don't
think outside of ourselves we just think
me me what I want I want a career I want
to go out and sometimes
you need people to be honest and tell
you that the world isn't about you and
we used to have older women that would
tell us that but now we have older women
that clap and co-sign bad behavior
instead of being honest with us and the
people that are honest get on and
you know they say that we can't judge
and we can't say anything but and I I
actually don't have a problem if it's
not hurting anybody you know honestly if
if a woman is not in debt okay because
debt everyone else has to pay for if a
woman's not overweight and the Health
Care System doesn't have to pay for her
she has a plan for retirement and she
wants to go be crazy with no kids I
don't care but the problem is we have a
bunch of women that make everybody pay
for their bad decisions they don't have
anything planned for retirement they're
in a lot of debt when they have kids
they don't raise them they make someone
else raise them someone else do it and
who has to suffer it's either the kids
the taxpayers or the men like if you
want to be miserable in your own
decisions I don't care but don't make
someone else pay for it and that is my
problem is we have a bunch of women and
mothers that would rather be Instagram
models than wives
and nobody tells us how stupid we look
and we should be mad at the older women
that gave us that advice and the simps
that co-signed it because the difference
is women live in delusion we don't even
know what's true and false I think
that's so obvious with with the the I'm
a 10 culture but the men they see it
they just let us do this stupid things
and nobody tells us we go through life
with these claps and these co-signs
where nobody tells us what is true and
what is false and we live in this
delusion for a lifetime and the people
that do suffer are the children yeah and
so you know speaking of older women
um that give bad advice this isn't this
isn't new like I I think there's a a
bigger and bigger percentage of women
that give bad advice like if you go to
the 70s to the 90 year old women maybe
it's like only 15 but then it goes up to
20 30 40 and it's 70
um and I I came across a tick tock talk
of a woman I'm saying to always assume
the worst in all men let's pull the clip
one of the reasons why I've had such an
amazing life is because my mom raised me
when she was a bitter divorced woman I'm
not even exaggerating she talks so much
crap
about men like like without even saying
like under her breath remarks so she'd
be like yeah if they ever pay for it you
know we're like don't count on them you
know it wasn't even like a lot of the
some of my favorite content creators on
here are divorced women those women are
going to tell you the truth more than
anyone and that's why like if I had any
advice to give
younger women especially in their 20s
you know teen like late teens 20s even
into like your early 30s depending on
you know what your goals are and what
you want in life or whatever but even
still don't believe me assume the worst
in all of them until proven otherwise
do you know why this is complete
you know
it's like just because you guys don't
have any good men in your life you don't
need to speak for everybody you know it
it's so it actually makes me really sad
watching this because you know I know
better A lot of women know better but
there's a lot of women that don't
have any advice on this stuff and they
go to the internet looking for guidance
and they find these crazy ladies and
they think and it's so funny because
exactly what I talk about it's right
there like right there you see how this
cycle continues there's a younger woman
saying listen to the older women and the
older women are divorced and bitter and
hate men
um and you know what's so crazy it's
like
when I when I think of the people that
have like helped me like done the most
selfless things for me in my life
um it's been a lot of guys a lot of men
like when I think of like one of one of
the best people I know you know I talk
about them all the time but like is my
dad and like literally the most selfless
guy I've ever met at the grocery store
he'll like help strangers with their
groceries like carry them to the car he
he's Dr like he had an employee once who
um was moving across States and like my
dad like he worked for my dad they ended
up like switching jobs my dad drove them
like eight hours to help them move like
he's just that type of guy and they're
just surrounded they're one they behave
like women that don't deserve protection
or provisioning so when you behave like
a harlot don't be mad when you get
Harlot treatment and they blame everyone
around them for the way that they treat
them instead of looking in the mirror
and thinking maybe I should act
a little different maybe maybe it's not
everybody else and again like I'm
showing you guys in front of your eyes
this is how it continues this is why we
have no wives anymore they're gone we're
in a post-marriage society and it's so
funny because they're talking about how
the wool is off of their eyes and I
actually think the way that they're
talking about themselves a lot of times
when women we'd like talk the stuff we
say like applies to us you think that
women have everything to lose in
marriage really
oh my God no the men have everything to
lose the men are rising up they're the
ones walking away from marriage and
relationships we still we still try we
still you know just keep shooting higher
and higher and higher we're like okay
let's try not the Entertainer let's get
the rapper then the athlete you know
what I mean like we try to get these men
to commit like we want relationships
with men out of our league you know
that's that's our thing but you just
have these women perpetuating the cycle
and it's it's really sad